ا قالت مصادر اعلاميه في جما من جماعه
انصار الله الحوثيين ان طيران التحالف
الامريكي البريطاني شن ما يقارب من عشر
غارات على العاصمه صنعاء مستهدفا جبل نقم
وقعده الديلم الجويه ومنطقه السواد والحفه
فيما استمر التحليق المكثف للمقاتلات
واستهدفت ايضا محافظات يمنيه اخرى منها
مديريه رداع بمحافظه البيضاء ومنطقه البرح
في الريف الغربي لمحافظه تعز
وقال مسؤول في جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين
ان الغارات الامريكيه والبريطانيه استهدفت
العاصمه صنعاء وتعز والبيضاء
وحجه من جانبه قال مسؤول امريكي للجزيره
ان القوات الامريكيه والبريطانيه وقوات
حليفه اخرى شن ضربات على مواقع تابعه
للحوثيين في اليمن واضافت المصادر ان
الضربات ضد مواقع الحوثيين استهدفت منصات
للصواريخ
والمسيرات
ومخازن اسلحه كما اكد مسؤول دفاعي امريكي
للجزيره ان ضربات القوات الامريكيه
والبريطانيه ضد الحوثيين هي مزيج من
الغارات الجويه والقصف
الصاروخي ضموا الينا من واشنطن مراسلتنا
بيسان ابو كويك وايضا من الحديده مراسلنا
سمير النمري مرحبا بكما بيسان ابدا معك
ويبدو بان هناك المزيد من التفاصيل عن
المسؤولين الامريكيين حول ضربات هذه
الليله في
اليمن بالفعل سلمى اخر ما وصلنا هو انه تم
استخدام صواريخ توماهوك في هذه الضربات
وقد صدر بيان مشترك عن كل من الولايات
المتحده
وبريطانيا بدعم من استراليا والبحرين
وكندا وهولندا يقول فيه ان القوات
الامريكيه
والبريطانيه شنت ضربات او جوله جديده من
الضربات على ثمانيه مواقع تابعه ل
الحوثيين في مناطق متعدده من اليمن كان
ذلك ايضا امر نقل حصلنا عليه من مسؤولين
امريكيين ل الجزيره بدعم من الدول الاربعه
استراليا وهولندا والبحرين وكندا وكان
لدينا معلومات ان هناك دول قدمت دعم غير
عملياتي وكان ذلك وفقا لمسؤول ووفق هذا
البيان الهدف من هذه الجوله الجديده من
الضربات المتناسبه والضروريه وفق البيان
هو لاضعاف وتعطيل قدرات الحوثيين الذين
هجموا وهددوا الملاحه العالميه التجاريه
هذه هي الضربه الاولى المشتركه الامريكيه
البريطانيه لهذا التحالف منذ الحادي عشر
من يناير حين تم استهداف 60 موقع ل
الحوثيين طبعا كان هناك ضربات اخرى
امريكيه فقط ووفق البيان فان ما تم
استهدافه هو مواقع ووحدات للتخزين مخازن
تحت الارض مواقع مرتبطه بصواريخ الحوثيين
وايضا اخرى متعلقه بالقدرات
الرقابه
الجويه طبعا الولايات المتحده
وهذه يعني وفق البيان ان الولايات المتحده
والتحالف الدولي لن تتوانى عن استهداف
الحوثييين
وحمايه الملاحه العالميه الدوليه بعد تلك
الهجمات التي تم شنها اكثر من 30 هجمه
استهدفت سفن تجاريه في منطقه البحر الاحمر
وخليج عدن منذ نوفمبر الماضي وان الولايات
المتحده هدفها هو
تخفيض التوتر واستعاده الاستقرار في منطقه
البحر الاحمر وحمايه
الملاحه البحريه في تلك المنطقه والموانئ
والمرافئ والممرات
المائيه طبعا كان هناك في وقت سابق اليوم
تصريحات للحوثيين بانهم استهدفوا سفينه
امريكيه هي اوشن جاز ولكن الولايات
المتحده ووفق مسؤول امريكي للجزيره نفت
ذلك بشده ووفق متحدث عن قياده النقل
البحري فان هذه السفينه اوشن جاز هي
مستاجره من قبل من قبل قياده النقل البحري
العسكري التابع للبحريه الامريكيه ولكن
يصف المزاعم مزاعم الحوثيين وفق ما قاله
للجزيره بانها
كاذبه وانه لم يتم استهداف اوشن جاز لذا
يعني تطورات كثيره هذه الليله وربما انها
ضربات كانت واسعه وفق هذا البيان نعم
بيسان سمير النمري انت موجود في الحديده
دعنا في اطار ما جرى التصريح به رسميا
والمعلومات الوارده ايضا
والحديث عن النفي الامريكي كيف
قوبل يعني من قبل صنعاء والحوثي فيما يخص
هذه السفينه
واستهدافها نعم سلمى بحسب مصادر اعلاميه
هنا لجماعه انصار الله الحوثيين فقد تم
استهداف عدد من المواقع العسكريه بنحو 13
غاره جويه هذه الغارات استهدفت قاعده
قاعده قاعده العسكريه في في صنعاء بنحو
اربع غارات قاعده الديلم الجويه وكذلك
ايضا معسكر الحفا بنحو اربع غارات اخرى
اخرى وبالاضافه الى غارتين في تعز واخرى
في محافظه البيضاء بحسب تلك المصادر وهي
مصادر في قياده جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين
فان هذه الضربات كانت على معسكرات ومواقع
عسكريه قد تم اخلائها ولانها تعرضت لضربات
كثيره جدا خلال الفترات القادمه وهي مخلاه
من جميع الجنود
وا والضباط داخل هذه داخل هذه القواعد
المواقع العسكريه هذه المصادر ايضا تؤكد
ان الهدف من هذه الضربات التي تشنها
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا هدفها ارضاء
الداخل الامريكي ومحاوله اغوائه كما يقول
قاده انصار الله وان هذه الضربات لن تؤثر
في هذه المرحله على قدراتهم العسكريه وان
الجماعه في طور تجربه او استخدام ادوات وا
صواريخ جديده في استهداف السفن الامريكيه
وكذلك السفن المتوجهه نحو الموانئ
الاسرائيليه كان قائد او زعيم الجماعه عبد
الملك الحوثي قد اكد في اخر خطاب له ان
مهما كانت الولايات المتحده ما تقوم به
الولايات المتحده سواء من عدوان امريكي
على اليمن او من حيث اعاده تصنيف الجماعه
لن يؤثر على موقف الجماعه في استمرار
استهداف السفن وان ذلك ياتي ضمن
خطوات قادتها الجماعه منذ اليوم الاول لما
تسميه العدوان على غزه حتى رفع الحصار عن
المدنيين هناك وادخال المساعدات هذه
الضربات التي نفذتها الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا قبل نحو ساعتين من الان تاتي
بعد ساعات من اعلان الجماعه ان استهداف
السفينه الامريكيه وهي سفينه شحن عسكريه
كما تقول كما قال قائد الناطق العسكري
باسم انصار الله الحوثيين بان هذه السفينه
كانت متوجهه في ميناء في خليج عدن وتم
استهدافها بصواريخ بحريه مناسبه وان
الاصابه مباشره سالت احد القيادات لماذا
تنفي الولايات المتحده ذلك فهو يقول ان
الولايات المتحده دائما ما كانت تنفي في
البدايه ثم تعترف لاحقا بالخسائر وبان
الجماعه عندما تعلن وتقول انها قد استهدفت
هذه السفينه باستهداف مباشر فانها تقول عن
ذلك عن درايه وتاكدت من مصادرها الميدانيه
الاستهدافات الاخيره سلمى تتم في خليج عدن
وهي مناطق بعيده نسبيا عن مناطق سيطره
الجماعه فمثلا هنا الحديده تبعد مئات
الكيلومترات عن تلك المناطق شكرا لك من
الحديده سمير النمريه وبيسان ابو كويك من
واشنطن